all right well apparently a lot of
people want me to talk about the
Assassin's Creed 3 ending and to be
honest with you guys I want to talk
about it too now first of all a fair bit
of warning and a lot a bit of logic if
you haven't beaten Assassin's Creed 3
yet and you don't want spoilers don't
watch this it's a video about the
Assassin's Creed 3 ending so yes there
are going to be spoilers in here however
if you've beaten Assassin's Creed 3 or
you just don't give a [ __ ] about
spoilers welcome friends so first of all
before we talk about the Assassin's
Creed 3 ending we have to set up the
Assassin's Creed 3 story and the
Assassin's Creed games actually they
take place in the year 2012 shocker I
know it's crazy right but Assassin's
Creed goes on the premise of genetic
memory when you pass your genes on to
your kids you pass on those memories and
they pass on their memories to their
kids it's not like it's a conscious
thing like they remember the past is
vividly the past of their ancestors
however at the genetic level they are in
there and so if you can access them you
could see the pass enter the Assassin's
Creed story and enter Desmond Miles
Desmond is actually a bartender he comes
from a long line of badasses the very
long story short Desmond goes into this
machine called the animus where he can
see the past lives of his ancestors does
that hold genetic memory thing I was
talking about and that's when your
playing is the Assassin's when you're
playing is Altair Ezio and now Connor
and each one of these Assassin's has
keys to a puzzle which will hopefully
lead to Desmond saving the world because
as the Mayans told us on December 21st
2012 the world's going to end the
[ __ ] that is the premise of the game
so at the end of Assassin's Creed 3
you're in this cave temple thing you go
through this door and you're like all
right i'ma save the world and you're
greeted by the holographic AI images of
Juno and Minerva who are they well in
the course of the Assassin's Creed story
you learned that there was an ancient
civilization long before us they were
really technologically advanced but they
couldn't stop their own demise so they
all got wiped out but they were
technologically advanced badasses and
they knew that this would happen again
to the next civilization which is us so
they laid out the groundwork for Desmond
Miles to save the world
so judo is there and she's like alright
Desmond all you have to do is touch this
orb and that big solar flare is not
going to cook people like the movie
knowing and [ __ ] then Minerva comes out
and she's like no don't do that Juno is
actually trapped in this cave temple
thing and if you do that if you touch
that orb it's gonna free her and she's
going to enslave mankind no solar flare
or anything like that but you're gonna
live under the Bootheel of this chick
[ __ ] be crazy
then Minerva tells you it's better to
let everyone cook and die free people
than to live
slave Desmond's also told that if he
lets the solar flare come and wipe
everyone out there will be a fraction of
civilization that does survive he will
be one of them and his name will be
passed on as a prophet and then a God
then his teachings will be used to
enslave people and you know like
Crusades and murder basically the life
cycle as we've known it will happen
again
so you're like okay cool game choice the
games gonna let me choose the ending
that's badass but it doesn't it just
kind of rise it out and choose this for
you and that's not really a big deal
it's just kind of an annoyance so like I
played Assassin's Creed 3 thinking that
I would get to choose the ending now
there is the argument that they want to
make Assassin's Creed 4 and if they're
going to make 4 they have to have a
definitive ending to 3 you can't just
choose there has to be like hey for
Lord's sake this did happen
however this little nitpick of not being
able to choose the ending isn't why
people are pissed about the ending to
Assassin's Creed 3 it's because this is
the conclusion to Desmond Miles story
and this is how it concludes Desmond
chooses he's like no with the solar
flare wiping most of humanity out
there's no hope there but if we do this
we save the world will release Juno but
we can still fight her off maybe
possibly one day maybe so he walks up
puts his hand on the orbs he's fries his
brain he falls over dead it's done then
Juno looks at Desmond's dead body and
she's like you played your part well
Desmond but now it's time for me to play
mine she steps over his dead body walks
right into the Cameron that's the aunt
[ __ ] be crazy that's the end of
Desmond story now to be clear I don't
think Desmond Miles dying at the end of
Assassin's Creed 3 is a bad thing I
think that's actually a good call I
think he should die him giving his life
to save the world shows how much he's
grown I'm just saying the execution of
it made it abysmally just useless he's
really abrupt cliffhanger endings
they're not strange and it's not like
it's out of the blue is pretty par for
the course for an assassin's Creed gang
all of the endings are like that it's
like a little bit of Revelation done so
the ending 2-3 could be seen as yeah
business as usual however it is the end
of Desmond Miles story and that's where
they screwed up because Desmond may have
started out as the looking-glass the
pair of eyes that you go through to see
the assassin so you can play as the main
character which is the assassin however
at a point in the Ezio story arc Desmond
became the main character I know the
exact moment to was when Ezio was
talking to the AI holographic projection
of Minerva and she's talking to him and
he talks to her and she interrupts him
she's like please don't interrupt me I
need to tell him this and SEO is like
tell who this and then she looks and
she's like you have to do this Desmond
and Su
like I'm confused who is Desmond but
Minerva knew that Desmond would be
watching this through SEO blew
everyone's mind at Blu Ezio's mind
Desmond's mine my mine at that point I
was like dude Desmond's like some sort
of modern-day Messiah that's badass
I hope they treat him like such and have
him die awesomely there's this other
sweet scene I think it was in Assassin's
Creed Revelations where SEO just stops
and he's like Desmond I don't know who
you are I don't know where you are but I
know you can hear me and so he just goes
on as to how important it is that
Desmond does what he needs to do but
it's clear that everything that happens
in the assassins world is so Desmond
does what he needs to do Desmond is the
main character and he's the character
that we players came to relate to you
gotta admit a lost bartender who's
stepping up to do what's right is more
relatable to the male 25 to 35
demographic than an assassin who kills
people
although Desmond becomes a badass
assassin who does kill people I'm just
saying it's it's true and from there
they polished his story more they've
polished his character more they've gone
deeper into his past they've showed him
step up and become the assassin he needs
to be he's like you know what I walked
away from that lifestyle but this is who
I am this is who I need to be this is my
destiny I am stepping up to this
responsibility so to wrap up Desmond
ultimate ending in about one minute of
him going I need to do this blood dad
that's not enough that's called boba
fett in him yeah boba fett he might as
well have had Han Solo hit his jet pack
accidentally and flown to the star Lac
pit and died and I know extended Laura
Star Wars Paras are gonna be like he
actually lived through that well look
not in the movies and not to me Boba
Fett died there and it was a terrible
death which is why every stupid death
afterwards I call being Boba Fett it I
mean if you look at the story of Desmond
and look at the ending when you hear
about it or if you see it on paper
you're probably like oh yeah that sounds
cool this guy who comes from a long line
of assassins is destined to be one
leaves it all behind he goes and becomes
a bartender he just wants to be
invisible he doesn't want anything to do
with that assassin world and he gets
drawn into it finds out that he has a
destiny to save the world he steps up
and he's like you know what I need to do
this because that's the man I need to be
like this error garnish story kind of a
little bit in modern-day with the
20-something year old bartender kind of
he gives his life and falls over dead
doing what he believes is right the man
has come so far from being a bartender
in New York it's awesome however
the execution had all that climb and it
looked awesome then he was like I need
to do this 30 seconds the ending needed
to be a little deeper we needed to feel
the gravity of it we wanted to we I mean
Desmond's estranged father's with him at
the end and desmond tells him to go take
a hike because he needs to do this and
he does you're not going to have any
really strong father-son dialogue I mean
he's his estranged father and they've
been kind of getting a little closer at
least reaching an understanding through
this whole ordeal a good father-son
bonding moment right there that would
have done wonders for the end you know
what it sounded cool cuz his father is
voiced by cue from Star Trek The Next
Generation so it would have been badass
no matter what he was saying it was like
the game makers of Assassin's Creed 3
didn't actually see Desmond how we saw
Desmond we saw Desmond as now the main
character the one that we relate to the
one the story actually revolves around
but they killed him off as if he was
just the looking glass pair of eyes that
he was an assassin's creed one like he
was the instrument to see the actual
main characters who were the assassins
and that's not true I'm interested to
see the next Assassin's Creed sure I
mean did you know is the entire human
race and slaved immediately she gonna
try to do it I imagine she's going to
work with the Templars to do it you know
cuz they're all about order through
control which is ironic that Desmond
chose the ending that he chose because I
would ultimately see that as the Templar
ending so that's what I feel about the
Assassin's Creed 3 ending the events
don't bother me the pacing and execution
that did it just kind of makes you feel
like oh well Desmond Miles is pretty
irrelevant as was his death the ending
just lacked the gravity of a Messiah
character giving his life to save the
world that's pretty much the gist of it
right so the Assassin's Creed 3 ending
what did you think of it I'm curious to
know so comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you